[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over the Venona defense and the
fidelity defense is a very aggressive
defense against the queen pawn opening
from white and i feel that as a black
player you really want to have a lot of
different defenses that you can throw it
white and d for being a very popular
opening for a white a lot of different
openings that you can choose from
obviously most players are familiar with
Queens gambit accepted Queens gambit
declined lines today we're going to be
going over the Benoni defense more
importantly the modern Benoni which i
believe to be the easiest variation of
the bodoni to play so we're gonna go
over the main line and kind of go over
the key concept that you want to think
about when playing the benoni so it
starts out with pawn to d4 and black
responds with Knight to f6 and then
White's going to from here just bring
this pawn to c4
and blacks going to respond with pawn to
c5 now
here very very infrequently you will see
white just capture this piece right here
but why it's gonna have a really hard
time holding on to this piece after
black simply plays pawn to e6 why it's
pretty much going to have to completely
destroy his Queen side and blacks gonna
have a really good game but more times
than not you're going to see what is the
Benoni defense which is why to d5 and
this situation right here is what they
refer to is the Benoni defense and today
we're gonna be going over the modern
Benoni you may have heard of like the
bingo gambit which is basically bringing
your pawn to b5 we're not gonna be going
over that today it's it's kind of a
harder gambit to play you know it is
very aggressive but today we're going to
be going over the bonner the modern
benoni and that basically starts with
pawn to e6 and what this does is a few
things as you can see white is already
trying to take center control of the
white squares he has a defense here from
the c-4 pawn and his pawn on d5 is very
very powerful so we want to right away
try to attack that piece now why has a
few options here
some of the more infrequent ones that
you'll see is pawn can always just come
to this d6 square you won't see that
very often but just in case it does come
across I just want you to know what you
can do you can simply just bring your
Queen to b6 here and it's basically
attacking this b2 pawn so white cannot
bring another defender here to let's say
the f4 square because then black can
simply come into the b2 square so you
won't see that very often
every now and then you'll see a player
capture here on e6 obviously why would
like to keep a spawn here but a lot of
times you will see this now if you do
see this happen make sure if you're
black that you capture with your F pawn
and basically if you capture with your
deep on here then Y can simply come in
and trade off Queens and you can no
longer Castle so it's always important
to look at which piece you're capturing
with so if white does decide to capture
it's not the main line you won't see it
as often make sure that you capture with
your epon now basically your next move
you can just simply push your pawn to d5
opening up the center usually in the
modern banana you're going to be in
shadow your Bishop to the g7 square but
since we have captured with our our F
pawn to e6 we're not going to do that
anymore but once we Castle kingside
we're gonna have this open file on the F
file semi open file which is going to be
very good for our rook so this is a good
situation but you won't see it very
often what you will see very often is
the main line and that is simply not
coming to c3 and this is the main line
it's adding another defender to this d5
square white really wants to have sooner
control against the Benoni and black
really wants to have control of the dark
squares and he's basically eventually
wants to fianchetto from the Kings side
and control the center from the dark
square so we'll look at what that looks
like after white develops Knight to c3
then black is going to capture obviously
we want to take away the center control
that white has and from here why it's
going to recapture you always want to
recapture towards the center which white
does and white has two defenders the
knight and the Queen so right now we
can't
this piece and this is a very good piece
for white it really is and this is going
to be a focus point of the game there's
White's control of the center house to
round this piece right here the d5 piece
so from here we're going to just simply
move our pawn up we obviously don't want
this this pawn going any farther you can
see black is already starting to take
control the center dark squares you can
see that white has control of the light
squares and we won't control the dark
squares so we're gonna go solidify our
position a little bit the d6 square is
weak so keep that in mind when you are
playing that is a huge weakness for
black so you always want to be watching
this square from here the main line
continues White's going to develop to F
or excuse me main line is going to be
pawn to e4 adding another defender to
the d5 square in basically putting a lot
more defense into it's strong middle
game and you can see why it's really
focusing on the light squares and so
blacks going to counter that and focus
on the dark squares and so what black is
normally gonna do from here is
fianchetto on the King side and that is
pawn to g6 and then White's going to
play pawn to f4 and then we're going to
fianchetto with our bishop here and this
is the situation that I want to look at
here if you can tell white has a very
strong center control and eventually
black is going to Castle kingside and
black is really trying to focus on the
dark squares here and you can see why
did anytime can come to Bishop to b5 and
check the King
and so there's a lot of things that you
want to look at in this situation a lot
of players here will simply play pawn to
a6 kind of you know stopping white from
coming in here but you want to make sure
going on later in the game that you
always pay attention born to your
weakness on d6 but - you want to look at
this strong point on d5 eventually white
is going to want to have an outpost on
this e six or this C six square with one
of the Knights so keep that in mind
eventually this game is going to bust
open once black castles King side he can
bring his his route to this semi open
fall on the e square on this efile and
it's going to be a wide-open game so you
want to keep that in mind you want to
control the dark square so you don't
want to trade off your dark square
Bishop your light square bishop since
white is controlling light squares if
you can trade off light square bishop x'
then go ahead and do that
because their light square bishop is
gonna be a lot more powerful so if you
get in the situation these are the
things you just want to keep in mind it
is a very aggressive style as you can
see this game is can pretty much open up
at any given time it's not quite as
closed as maybe a Queens gambit accepted
line or Queens gambit declined line so
if you're looking for something a little
bit different and you want possibly just
to be really aggressive then go ahead
and try out the benoni I feel like it
plays really well so hope you guys enjoy
this hopefully the next time you come
across a d4 opening you can try this out
and have success with it
if you have an artist to try please
subscribe and I will see you guys next
video thanks for watch